[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our Bible question and answer
program where we get the privilege of
answering your questions from the word
of God it is one of our favorite
programs and from the emails and
contacts we've been getting it is also
one of your favorite programs so we are
very very happy for that that you tune
in each day when this program is aired
and that you send in your questions and
we get the privilege of answering those
questions I am in the company of two
students of the word and perhaps that's
the best praise that can be given to
anybody that they study the word they
believe the word they are edified by the
word and they're teachers of the word to
my right Pastor Daniel Miranda Pastor
good to have you here it's good to be
here and learning from voices of
experience
you can say that because he's a baby
compared to us you know
speak for yourself okay very good
but it's good to have some young fresh
blood in amen in the room and we praise
the Lord for that I won't say how much
older we are than he but I'll say you
and I are in the same zip code yes not
on the same street but we are in the
same thing and we praise the Lord for
that and this is of course our our
founder our president and principal
speaker Pastor Stephen bore
and as you can see we we like each other
company the the rumors are true we get
along well uh we like each other's
company we like to study the world
together and uh we have a good time in
this particular program let me say now
should you want to join in on the fun
we would love to have you do so contact
us at
um TV at some
tv.org that's TV at
sumtv.org send in your questions and we
will get to them as soon as we possibly
can if you're looking at these rather
impressive piles that we have before us
you realize that a lot of questions are
coming in
and sometimes uh people send in two or
three questions yes or two or three of
the same questions yes so if you don't
hear your question in a week or two
after you send it we're going to get to
it we don't lose any we don't throw any
away we will get to them but rather than
rush through the answers we like to take
our time with the answers to try to give
do deference to your questions and to
answer them thoroughly from the word of
God and we'll we make you this promise
that if an answer can be found in the
word of God we will find that answer and
get it to you from the word of God we're
a little late in Earth's history to be
listening to the Mind of Men what you
need what we want to give is the word of
God so we will take the time to find
your answer from the word of God and
then give it to you so we may not rush
through these questions we will give
them do difference as we need to do so
in these last days Pastor Moore if you
would please open us up with prayer then
we will begin with our first question
Father in heaven we come to your throne
boldly
because we come in the name of Jesus
we know that we're never supposed to
open your word without prayer
because our wisdom is limited your
wisdom is unlimited
and we need your wisdom to answer these
questions
so we ask for the presence of your Holy
Spirit as we open your word
that our answers might be based on your
word
and that those who are watching this
program might be blessed in their
spiritual life enriched as we study
together
this we pray in the precious name of
Jesus amen amen amen and amen well
Gentlemen We launch out the first
question is coming from Davis
the last name is a rather impressive one
I suspect from Africa and I think I'm
going to pass on it uh Davis
you've got a name that is a little uh
conflicting to this American tongue but
Davis and he wants to know how was Jesus
tempted
um perhaps I'll read the question hello
Pastor I have a question for you in
Hebrews chapter 4 15 it says Christ was
tempted just as we attempted James 1
13-14 says the way we are tempted
everyone is tempted when it's drawn by
his own her own desires and when desire
is conceived sin occurs so if Christ was
tempted Justice we are tempted it means
he had to be tempted excuse me within
his body and also outside from my
understanding but I got this question
uh in seven ABC chapter seven uh
Adventist Bible commentary I suspect
that is that says Christ never had evil
propensities what does the prophetess
mean here in this chapter because I'm
not getting her message uh I'll be
waiting for your answer interesting
question we ought to take our time with
it amen
well we need to first of all read the
verses from the book of James
just as they are written in the word of
God so let's read verses 13 through 15
actually
and maybe we can have Daniel read that
passage James chapter 1 and verses 13
through 15 so that we get the complete
picture
okay I'm reading from the new King James
version the Bible says here let no one
say when he is tempted I am tempted by
God for God cannot be tempted by evil
nor does he himself tempt anyone verse
14 but each one is tempted when he is
drawn away by his own desires and
enticed then when desire has conceived
it gives birth to sin and sin when it is
full grown brings forth death
okay so this is the passage um I might
just make a comment here
um
sin is a process many times yeah it's
not merely an act
you have for example Eve
you know she saw that the fruit was nice
looking that it appeared to be tasty
and then it said she desired it
then she took it
and ate it and of course the result was
sin
now what is the difference between Jesus
and us
we have these internal internal desires
that we respond to that eventually
produces sin
and as a result of sin death
Jesus had those what we may call
internal Temptations but the instant
that they came
he shut them down he did not allow his
interior to be enticed which would
ultimately lead to the action
and so um it's not that he was not
tempted as we are because he was tempted
as we are not only by external uh things
but also by the the internal man but
Jesus never actually had the inclination
the moment the Temptation came he was
never had never had a propensity never
had a tendency never had an inclination
all of these are synonyms not never had
any of those he cut off the Temptation
the instant that it came with us you
know we play with the Temptation and we
allow you know the inclination to
manifest itself in sinful action which
ultimately leads to death right and and
also a point that we need to emphasize
here the person here Davis is is
referring to seven Bible commentary
which most likely this is the famous
Baker's letter where it's found about
where where Ellen White says that Jesus
didn't have any propensities you know
Jesus did not have any cultivated
Tendencies right no evil he never
cultivated any sinful propensities now
he he was born with with an inheritance
of sin sinful inheritance infirmities
infirmities yes but that doesn't make
him a sinner or that doesn't make him
exactly like one of us because he never
as you just explained uh never yielded
even in the minimum to those Temptations
his nature recoiled
from from Evil yes Jesus had a fully
functioning intact relationship with his
father
uh and that that
kept him from the propensities which we
have we have to develop
that relationship Christ came with that
relationship uh in intact so he wasn't
he had he did not have the leanings you
know there's an interesting text that
I've played with over the years in in
John chapter I've got it here on my
phone uh 14 verse 30 the king the prince
of this world comes uh and he has
nothing in me you know Christ is saying
there's nothing there's no hook there's
nothing for him to grab onto because I
have I have no I've there's nothing in
me that is in League with him now some
people may say well Christ came with
this intact relationship he kind of had
an advantage uh and I know you've got a
story coming up I got a quick one too
um I was doing it I was doing a wedding
and uh years ago and the the this time
the groom was late bride was was on time
we were sitting in a study Brides there
uh Grooms there uh uh groomers coming
and uh they were doing some remodeling
of the church so the walls were torn
down and the studs we're showing and uh
into that office uh the became a fairly
good sized Mouse
and everybody scattered the bride hopped
up on my desk and the Bridesmaids are
upon the credenz everybody scattered and
the the little boy who carried the Bible
had a little white tuxedo I don't know
where he disappeared to but when when
the mouse left and the boy came back
that tuxedo was black okay it was filthy
and there was no time to change it we
just had to take the jacket off and he
just went down in his you know his pants
and his his little his little bow tie
and I said to myself at that time you
know is it easier to get clean or stay
clean you know once you are clean it's
it's just as hard to stay clean once you
are clean so Christ didn't have it
wasn't like he got a pass on on on work
with his father uh he came clean but he
had to stay clean he had the infirmities
he had the weakness he had six thousand
a year or four thousand years back then
of of human degeneration but he didn't
have this leaning towards sin that we
have uh uh but he had to keep that it
was tested it was tried so as we have to
get clean he had to stay clean and both
are are awful lot of work right yeah
yeah
um
so basically
the more we respond
to our internal inclinations they
stronger they become yes very true and
you know Temptation becomes a piece of
cake like for example if we hooked
hooked on coffee or hooked on drugs it's
very easy to to give in to the
inclination because of previous
experience but Jesus the instant that
the Temptation came
that is that Jesus rejected he never was
never inclined he never he was never
never had the tendency to do what his
internal inclination what Satan tried to
get his inclination to do okay and you
know an example of that is in the Garden
of Gethsemane
did he suffer internal Temptations in
the Garden of Gethsemane you better
believe he was Ellen White says that
with his Fierce Temptation Satan tempted
Christ he said to him listen if you go
forward to this you're never going to
see your father's face ever again no and
Jesus was Jesus inclined to say hmm
should I do it or should I not do it no
the incident came Ellen White says that
he trusted in his father he knew his
father and he was Victor by faith
there is a point here that I want to
mention which is very important and is
that when Hebrews 4 4 15 says that
Christ was tempted in all points like as
we are
that doesn't mean that Christ was
tempted in all the specific things right
he was tempted in principle yes there
are things today that were not back then
in Jesus's time like television music
well music yes but uh you know
some of the things social media as we
have it today
uh some people say well how can Jesus
relate to a homosexual for example or
how could Jesus relate to
a drug addict
if I don't think he had those
Temptations or an adulterer how could he
relate to them well Jesus was tempted in
principle and I think the best summary
that that or the three Temptations
that summarizes all the Temptations that
human beings suffer are the three
Temptations in the wilderness where
Jesus was tempted in the physical area
that's the first Temptation in the
mental area that's the second Temptation
and the spiritual area which is the
third Temptation and that encompasses
all the different areas in which we are
tempted Jesus was tempted to believe the
same lie that we are tempted to believe
which manifests in different behaviors
but it's the same life yeah to follow up
on your example about the three
Temptations in the wilderness Jerry
Reynolds Hoffman which I'm sure that CA
knows the name you might not he was a
very successful evangelist in the
Adventist Church
and he gave an illustration which is uh
kind of a secular illustration but it
illustrates the point that Jesus was
tempted in categories of Temptation not
specific Temptations He gave this
example he said supposing that this
individual is involved in a shipwreck
he's the only one that survives and he
ends up on a deserted island
and fortunately there's a stream of
water you know that he can drink from
but there's absolutely no food on the
deserted island and he just you know for
40 days he doesn't have anything to eat
he only has water to drink and then in
the distance he sees he sees a ship and
so with a little energy that he has he
you know he moves his arm signaling to
the ship to come to where he is and if
the ship sees him and so they come and
and the captain gets off the ship and he
has this beautiful shapely woman and he
has a plate of food and he says to this
man choose which one you want
what will he choose the food because
hunger is a stronger urge yes than sex
yes and so when Jesus was tempted with
Hunger he was tempted with all physical
Temptations exactly yes all category of
physical Temptations now some people
might not like the example but I think
it illustrates the point exactly that
Jesus was tempted in a Temptation that
would include all of the categories that
have to do with this physical nature
yeah I think this is a very important
point and and and that we we need to lay
on it just a little bit because there
are those who sometimes Harbor in their
minds and in their hearts that Christ
had some sort of advantage that in these
last days since we have all of these new
iterations of sin that Christ could not
possibly know what I'm going through he
didn't have internet he didn't have
pornography he didn't have bars right he
didn't have brothels he didn't have you
know so many things he didn't have
cigarettes so many many things but but
even though he was doesn't tempted in
these actual manifestations of sin the
categories and when you when you call
that MSN categories
the the categories of sin uh he was he
was tempted and so he he could relate he
could understand because uh though we we
invent so many new things each year uh
more ways to get sick more ways to get
hurt more ways to die Christ was tempted
into all of these categories including
the category to to take his future out
of the hands of his father and handle
his own business which we also attempted
to do uh so he was successful in not
falling in any of those categories and
so we can look to him regardless of what
our sin is because we know that he was
tempted in all points like as we are
well said well when when we diagnose sin
even though sin is a mystery one cannot
explain it fully but sin Begins by
accepting a lie of Satan that's what we
see in the Garden of Eden and there are
lies
so sin is manifested we believe the lie
and then there is an external
manifestation of the behavior it could
be even in the feelings the behavior or
even actions
so
some lies are manifested in different
ways so for example the lie that I am
not accepted or I am not loved Jesus was
tempted with those lies that he was not
accepted that he was not loved through
that he was not good enough which
psychologically are the same thought
patterns that lead someone to
prostitution and to all these different
things so Jesus didn't have to become a
prostitute if you will with all
reverence to identified with that
specific person but Jesus was tempted
with the same lie with which these
people are tempted to which believed
that leads them into this sinful
Behavior yeah you know I am it reminds
me of my experience that I had many
years ago towards the beginning of a
Ministry
an individual came to me and said he was
a smoker heavy smoker three packs a day
and he said to me
um how could Jesus understand me if he
never smoked he doesn't know how strong
the urge to smoke is so how can he
understand me
so I thought and I said to him now let
me give you an illustration let's
suppose that you're walking down a path
and suddenly you step into quicksand and
you start sinking in the quicksand
and I said what do you think uh what
would you prefer would you prefer to
have someone in the quicksand syncing
with you or would you rather have
somebody on Solid Ground that can pull
you out and I said you know if Jesus had
smoked he'd be sinner in this in the
quicksand with you praise the Lord he
didn't sin and therefore he's able to
pull you out yeah yeah so so he was
tempted in all things yet without sin is
what the text says and if he had sinned
how could he help us he can't help us
but he did suffer the agonizing
Temptations
in every sense that we suffer amen yeah
you know last one and we can leave this
point uh one of the greatest
lies ever put upon a human being uh
human beings is it's my body I can do
what I want you know
um and and out of that comes I can drink
what I want I can eat what I want I can
take it where I want I can uh abortion
you know the the feel is so wide uh and
yet we've got uh First Corinthians 3 16
and 17 6 6 19 and 20. we're bought with
a price we're we it's not your body it
it has been paid for by by God and
Christ understood that that he belonged
to God he needed to keep his his
physical form and tip top shape so
certain things he couldn't do uh certain
things he certain things he could not
say certain places he could not take it
because he knew that he belonged to God
and if we had that understanding there
would be so much that we do that the
world does today that it would not do if
we really weren't deceived into thinking
that it's my body I can do whatever I
want you know in the in the abortion
discuss question these days you know you
find these people who are demonstrating
and they'll have a sign that says my
body my choice that needs to be changed
to his body his choice his choice the
Lord's Choice amen because God is The
Giver of Life
and therefore uh I don't have a right to
do with life the cree what God created
life I don't have any right to end that
life amen because it's his yeah it's not
mine yes yes
so it is is very Broad and hopefully we
have given uh due time and deference to
your question David uh Davis and thank
you so very much for it it is an
important question and one that I
suspect many people have asked
themselves and wrestled with over uh the
years uh did Christ have an advantage
did he have something that we don't have
access to and the answer is no all that
he had we can have in our relationship
with God through the power and presence
of the Holy Spirit and he had greater
Temptations than us how many times has
has somebody tempted you to turn stones
into bread
the temptation to use his divinity yes
and that was even greater than that
right yes yes yes to for his own
Advantage yeah because he knew he had it
he had the power right yeah when he told
Peter and Rebecca there's a question
again now
what did he told me to get behind me
Satan Peter's saying you're not going
through this I'm not I'm not letting you
go through this we're going to find
another way he knew that would say
the idea that that I don't have to go
through trouble and I hear this from
pulpits when you come to the Lord your
troubles are over oh have mercy but when
you come to the Lord your troubles just
begin
what you get is straight to meet those
troubles but don't don't think that the
Christian walk is an easy Tiptoe Through
the Tulips it is not you've got to fight
against yourself which is the strongest
battle you'll ever fight but luckily I
shouldn't say luckily praise God we
don't fight alone with the help of
omnipotence amen already Daniel I think
you've got the next question if you've
got to read that for us this question
comes from Noah Bennett
and from India
I have a question what is Jacob's time
of trouble when does it happen
is it true that it happens during or
after the seventh place and after the
close of probation
do people confess all their sins at that
time
how can they confess all their sins if
the probation was closed
I am a bit confused in this can I get
some clear answers from scripture as
well as from the spirit of Prophecy
thank you oh wonderful someone from
India we greet you and and thank you for
sending your question amen it's first of
all it's nice to know that that we are
we are reaching all the way to the
Indian subcontinent uh and that the
footprint goes there Pastor Watson
well the bottom line is that from the
spirit of Prophecy it's very clear that
the time of Jacob's trouble takes place
after the close of probation right
towards the end of the Great Tribulation
that's mentioned in Matthew 24 and verse
21. uh
and we know this from several places in
the Bible as well
um you know Ellen White in the chapter
on the time of trouble actually refers
extensively to the experience of Jacob
and she Begins the chapter with Daniel
12 1 the standing up of Michael which is
the close of probation yes and then it
says there will be a time of trouble uh
the same in Matthew chapter 24 verse 21
it speaks about God's people fleeing and
then the time of trouble begins so
there's Jeremiah chapter 30 verses 5
through 9 also speaks of the time of
Jacob's trouble as happening after the
close of probation so
um you know this person who asked this
question uh Noah actually answered his
own question uh when he said how can
they confess all their sins if the
probation was closed well they can't
because once probation is closed the
cleansing of the sanctuary is finished
and God's people will have to live
without an intercessor and Jesus will
leave the sanctuary that means there is
more no more intercession for since
precisely but Jesus will still intercede
and and plead or I would say Grant and
help those who are crying and sighing
every day and night during the time of
trouble he'll protect them he's like he
stands he's it says in Daniel chapter 12
verse 1 he stands in favor of his people
so you know this idea some people say oh
I don't want to go through the time of
trouble because you're going to be on
your own well you're not going to be on
your own you're gonna you're not going
to be able to send your sins to the
sanctuary because the sanctuary has been
cleansed but you are going to be able to
claim the protection of Christ after all
Christ says lo I am with you always not
not until the close of probation amen
Until the End of the Age yes yes so
let's let's go back and and and Define
what Jacob's trouble is where's the
parallel coming from Pastor you want to
take a snap of that that's coming from
Genesis chapter 32 where Esau is coming
to he thinks he's coming to destroy
Jacob and his family and Jacob cries out
to the Lord to deliver him from the
wrath of his brother yes and you know
that's parallel to God's people being
under a death decree at the after the
close of probation crying out to God for
deliverance and God will deliver them
like Jacob did amen because Jacob had to
had to cry and sigh to the Lord make
sure that his sins had been forgiven
previously in order to claim God's
protection yeah so where I'm I'm going
with this that this is as much a
spiritual wrestling as it is a physical
one yes it's it's are my sins forgiven
have I am everything has everything been
taken of it's a it's a mental gymnastic
as much as a a physical one because we
we have been sealed the probation has
closed so what will be will be but um uh
there is this this mental wrestling I
think the point that you you brought out
very very uh just a moment ago is very
very important the fact that God will be
with us too the very end right in fact
he will be us through the very end amen
amen can we see him face to face he's
never going to leave us never going to
forsake us right even though this time
of wrestling when we may not be sure he
is sure and our Salvation is sure this
is a good question uh boy gentlemen our
time has fast slipped into eternity
we're down to the last several seconds
hopefully we pray that you have been
edified you have been inspired and
informed during this last little bit
that we've been together we'll see you
again next time keep on studying the
word of God and we pray God's blessing
upon you and your walk with him amen
foreign
[Music]